start off here these past couple of days
we've had several show announcements
coming to sin city and one of them is
taking us back to the early 90s we're
talking about boombox a red vegas
residency on shuffle i love that
happening this summer at the westgate
performances from celo greene naughty by
nature
kid and play jj fat and theo austin of
snap we got a chance to talk to
christopher reed himself also known as
who kindle
kid from kid and play yeah about this
residency check it out
i think there's a uni a uniqueness in in
the way that we're going to bring the
show to you guys uh like kind of in
boombox form you know it'll be a song
from this artist it's on from that
artist hey here come play and i you know
hosting the event bringing it bringing
the groups out uh excuse me a lot of
great interaction uh with the audience
and uh
so we're very very very excited about it
these are some artists that says
something that i know who all these
people are i know them i know it's in
said kid and play i think they were
trying to make me look you know
like i didn't know you're good come on
the boombox performers will also be
accompanied by a live dj and drummer
nostalgic videos dancers and a whole lot
more and speaking of bringing nostalgia
back a kid again has a special message
for those attending their residency
feel free
you know what i'm saying to bring out
your funky stuff you know what i'm
saying
i know not everything's not everything's
gonna fit but
i don't know bring the gold chain or i
don't know just bring some some kind of
memorabilia uh to kind of transport uh
we can transport ourselves back to a
happier time
i love it boombox a vegas residency on
shuffle brings the party to the west
gate may 11th through the 15th and may
18th through the 22nd tickets go on sale
tomorrow morning and we're all doing
little shuffles and dances in here
really